-We have exactly four shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 4 days left ♪
-That's right! Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a boom-bastic Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Since there are four shows left,
let's open door number 4.
-Let's do it.
[ Drumroll ]
-Yep.
Go for it.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Can we dim the lights?
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
It's a good one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who's sitting at 430?!
Yeah!
Come on, bud!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey!
Come on over!
You're over there.
Nice to see you, brother.
Go over there.
Hey, what is your name,
and where are you from?
-Giovanni.
Cincinnati, Ohio.
-Hey, that's what I'm talking
about -- Cincinnati, Ohio!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've been to Cincinnati
when it's cold.
And, man, oh, man,
nothing like having
the pasta with chili on it,
right?
-Skyline.
-Yeah, Skyline, exactly.
And I go there,
and I have to wear a sweater
'cause it's so cold.
Do you have a sweater like this?
-I do not.
-Yeah.
Now you do.
Would you like to try it on
for everyone?
-I would love to.
-Here you go, bud.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This will be perfect.
Go to Skyline -- look at this.
Wow.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh, it's subtle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so good.
It looks good.
Look at you.
Come on, look at him.
That's what
I'm talking about, man.
It looks great.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Give it up
for our winner right there.
Round of applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.